Emme peas draw up the shortlist of three  candidates from the eight nominees for  the 2018 Sakharov Prize for freedom of  thought the prize will be awarded in  December Parliament is calling for a  full investigation into how Facebook  data was misused for political purposes  after the Facebook CEO was questioned by  MEP s over the Cambridge analytic a  scandal members vote on new rules to  reduce plastic in the sea and ban the  most commonly found single-use items  such as cutlery plates plastic cotton  buds and straws by 2021 every year  passengers travel more than 500 billion  kilometers on Europe's rail network  Parliament is debating tougher rules to  protect their rights similar to those  for airline passengers how has voting  technology affected the credibility of  elections Parliament hosts a high-level  conference to discuss this and other  challenges facing election observation  missions around the world